[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i'd like to welcome on to the podcast
thank you so much for being able to be
here virtually uh you all know him and i
love him obviously already we got josh
potter
thank you thank you for having me uh
thank you for being here we got through
our technical difficulties and now we
are oh no i i'm not sure uh could have
been on my end too the zoom seems to
work better than google meets um so i'll
remember that going
going forward but uh yeah i had to wear
the bills jersey today because we had uh
josh on and also it's just a good excuse
it's not i have an oj jersey and i
barely get to wear it so this is one of
the this is one of the few times i
always wondered as a bills fan if it's a
touchy subject no no i love oj
you know i say
you know it's a shame what happened to
nicole and ron but i mean the man ran
two thousand yards
yeah
and heisman you know he's still up on
our wall of fame
yeah he's also still he sells the bust
up in um
in the pro football hall of fame but i
didn't know he was still in the stadium
yeah yeah i'm sure what i mean we're
supposed to get a new one
in uh 2026 here coming up so yeah i'm
sure his name will like be forgotten in
the move i'm right we're gonna guess
that right now just lost lost longer
yeah people love oj but if you go to the
build stadium you'll see a ton of og
jerseys that's crazy because if you
think about that compared to like
how how they did joe paw when all that
went down taking down the stats just
erasing him from history basically that
was more the institution than it was
like think about what happened when they
did do that
when they fired them there was like
riots as if george floyd was murdered it
was very true you know what i mean so
it was like bananas that's the way
that's kind of how bill's fans are we're
like
you know it's a shame he murdered those
people but you know he's still
yeah
of all time that's true that's the white
person's george floyd is joe turner's
statue being removed
so uh best buffalo bill of all time how
do you feel about the future obviously
you got josh allen uh with the reigns
now um how did it's got to be a good
time to be a bills fan oh yeah i love it
it's uh
it's better than ever i mean
people were asking me you know was i sad
when we lost to the chiefs or whatever
and i was obviously i was like upset
that we lost but it's all this is like
cherry on top like from
the years that i was 13
until i was 32 we didn't make the
playoffs yeah it was like this was this
is all bonus stuff yeah the fact that
we're in the mixes
still feels good to me you know what i
mean that's how i feel because i'm
actually i'm a bengals fan and oh so i
had no expectations nothing no anything
for this this season um you know we just
got done tanking like i had no
expectations so then the fact that they
even made the playoffs me and my dad and
my brother were all so excited about and
then like they keep winning and they
keep obviously it's exciting but then
it's like how do you feel after they
lost the super bowl and it's like i
barely even just got over the fact that
they made it to the super bowl like it's
like that we were there yeah like i mean
yeah especially the i mean the bengals
just had the number one overall pick
like two years ago it's crazy that they
are in the super bowl and i it made me
think like all the years the bills
missed the super bowl we weren't like
epically bad there was like a couple
times we'd be in the top five for draft
picks but for the most part it was like
nine and seven eight and eight right you
know
that can kill a franchise kind of yeah
it doesn't make you go this way or this
yeah it's kind of like if you just stay
in here because you can't get a like
impact
right then you're [ __ ] you know so but
also it's hard to see your team just
tank like i i
the year that they were going after
burro and it was obvious so it's like
okay i'm happy that they're going to get
joe burrow i'm obviou i'm also an ohio
state guy so it's like all right i like
joe burrow i i like that they're going
but it's like this sucks like every
sunday i'm just like i don't need i
don't even even have anything to watch
like
you know so i those eight and eight
seasons at least it's like okay my guys
are trying like they're you know that
they're giving it you're all because
watching a tanking team it's it's brutal
but
who was the quarterback during the
tanking time was it uh
allen or whatever the other allen uh
they had yeah they had they like dalton
started the first year or first game and
then they like
pulled him and and
rotated a few guys it was um
his last name was alan something and
then it was uh it wasn't the one that
was like there was there's like three
allens floating around now obviously not
josh allen yeah it was some like skinny
white guy that could kind of run a
little bit but like he was just out
there getting clobbered like by still
the worst o-line in the league and
even this season i thought you had the
worst o-line in the league and here and
then you went to super bowl so you're
like all right well oh yeah you get
sacked 11 times in tennessee and still
win that game that is the worst aligned
in the league so would you that but that
game i would say uh that playoff game
against the chiefs i think that's the
best
football game i've ever watched maybe
besides the other chiefs game against
the rams i think it was a monday night
it was a prime time game like three
three years ago or something yeah
yeah that was crazy
i mean i had i was it was too i had too
much skin in the game to like recognize
that also in that moment i was watching
it i had a show that night in milwaukee
and i was watching it
uh in the green room
and then the fourth quarter started when
i had to go on stage and i made them put
the screen down behind me and like play
the game and i just did like
commentating of the game for like an
hour
plus until it's kind of awesome actually
the audience like why i put it up on my
patreon like the whole thing like the
audience had to watch the game with me
and they and they you know to their
credit were like getting into it because
it was such a great game yeah um
but
i think for me like in that season
it's kind of the same thing because i
didn't have any skin in the game it was
that game between the chargers and the
raiders
like week 18
if they tied they both would have made
the playoffs oh yeah yeah
just because it almost tied like it was
at the end of overtime yeah and it was
almost over i thought that was i wish it
tied it would have made it even more
perfect but that was the most like
because i had no real skin in the game i
just was kind of rooting for the tie
right that was the most exciting
football game i've ever watched the most
exciting game ever was rooting for a tie
rooting yeah
that's crazy because they admitted that
there was like a miked up conversation
and there was someone that said yeah we
were gonna we were gonna take them well
yeah they because they it would help
both of them it was joe herbert had to
like take the knee
and he didn't they they did a running
play and
so i think they like lost some yards or
something it took him out of
field goal range or something like that
and yeah it was a wacky they came down
yeah then they just did they ran a
stupid play where it was like what are
you doing just take the need
i remember that gave him the ball back
yeah everyone was saying like they
should bet for an exact tie or bet to
get go to overtime or like those those
odds are so crazy on that oh sure
usually you don't think that the teams
are like aware of these weird trends
that all the fans were talking about but
it's oh they knew i mean and they in and
they knew very hardly probably because
the nfl was like really like
there was even press conference stuff
beforehand where they were like we're
not going for a time we're not going to
go for a tie because what's stopping
both teams from being like let's just
make it zero zero yeah it helps both of
us technically yeah exactly and that's
not really
i don't think that's i mean the nfl's
probably that's a bad product it'd be
super boring and it seems like kind of
yeah that's the thing the nfl wants
competitiveness they don't want anyone
to like
[ __ ] up on purpose just for the sake of
you know the tie or technically i don't
know what would be wrong with that like
either do i i mean if it's what you want
yeah exactly i remember that but that
that chiefs that playoff game it was
exciting for me besides just seeing all
the you know great quarterbacks
high-flying action i had a parlay in
place a eight-game parlay and it was oh
[ __ ] five bucks to win like close to 800
i think and obviously i never hit these
they're eight gamers i suck at gambling
but you gotta go for the big parlay and
the last piece was the over in that game
and it looked terrible for like the
first half yeah at the first half going
into the second half i was watching it
with my roommates i was like well it's
done you know because we were it's the
last leg we're all watching for this and
it's the nfl playoffs obviously and then
i'm complaining i'm like it's done
whatever i can't believe i lost complain
and then
two minutes left they doubled the score
oh yeah it went crazy all of a sudden it
was just touchdown like after touchdown
after touchdown that's the thing i love
about the over is it's never really dead
especially in football yeah it's it's
just so like
you just feel like you're clenching it
the whole time trying i think i had the
over two that day
but i was you know i had the bills
obviously i parlayed it with the bills
to win so they lost and that [ __ ] it
up but i would have won a bunch of money
myself on that if the bills i bet the
bill's like every game like an idiot i'm
i'm a heart gambler and i bet oh she's
always with my heart it's bad that's why
i like baseball because i really have no
like
true fandom i just like every like
players and stories and stuff so i just
like baseball i like all the teams
people are like what's your favorite
team i'm like i've got 30 of them i love
it right that makes sense yeah you have
a favorite do you have a favorite uh bat
in baseball
a favorite uh like a batter uh no like
like a favorite like uh line to bet like
i like to do no runs first innings
sometimes oh that's fun that's fun i i
like doing that sometimes too but then
it's like so shot when it's i like the
whole game so yeah you know i i do
parlays you know i try to do like um
like right now i did a three game parlay
of the morning games i do it based off
like this those slates of what i was
like so there's like three morning games
i'll bet up harley with all three of
them
and um i like doing that and i like just
like
like on days like where i'm stuck at
home or i'm laid up or whatever i love
watching baseball all day so i'll just
do
three-way parlays or sometimes just two
you know but sometimes i'll do three
just to keep it spicy that that that's a
good way to i like those big numbers
like you said yeah for sure and it's
because it like there's no stake in this
game there are a bunch of random teams
but now there is because you got a
little skin in the game right yeah no
and i just love watching baseball so i
will bet on like almost every game that
i watch
what do you think the baseball
baseball's kind of been declining i feel
like in the in the public eye like
especially my generation i obviously
everyone grows up t-ball baseball and
stuff and then it felt like for me as
soon as i was done playing it myself i
just lost a lot of interest
um
in the mlb i feel like the highlights
that like they have a strict thing about
like releasing their highlights on
social media like
like they've lacked that a little bit i
feel um
and they're they're not doing themselves
any favors that that's for sure but
there is like a group of young
awesome players that are like so fun
that i feel like will get kids
back into it again you know what i mean
like there's just fun players right now
it's like fernando tatis jr and like
francisco lindor like there's just tim
anderson there's like exciting
people that are coming up now
yeah and i think it's like
not like gonna come back i mean i don't
know what it's down from i've only
gotten you into it in recent years i
feel like it was down
post steroid era
a little bit more than it is even now
like i feel like they're kind of in an
incline even though it's slow yeah um
but yeah the like i feel like right
after the steroids thing people are just
like [ __ ] this yeah and i [ __ ] love
the steroids i say bring them back i say
bring them back too it's way more than
cleaning let's get some steroids going
and let them in the hall of fame that's
for sure well what do you think so
you're a you're a you're a gambler what
do you think about uh pete rose what do
you think about oh you should be in hall
of fame [ __ ] um at least as a player
like at least as a as a hitter sure
exactly yeah um
who was the nfl player that just got
suspended for oh calvin ridley
he wasn't even playing he was like
sidelined people are like insider
knowledge who cares i i love insider
knowledge like that's the whole point
and um and the inside knowledge isn't
even that crazy like everyone knows
you're trying to win the game it's not
like he can like be like we're gonna try
to win extra hard this week like you're
trying to win every game
yeah and he doesn't get like secret
reports that we don't get or something
maybe he gets to like he has a friend on
the one team that's like oh i have the
flu today and i'm not feeling great yeah
maybe that's something i don't know but
regardless if that's falcons too so it's
like that's the same thing with pete
rose he wasn't ever betting against
himself he was betting on him like he
was betting on himself which i i think
like that makes it look like he has even
more skin in the game yeah to get the
win you know the only thing and i am i'm
on pete rose's side but the only thing
that i've heard brought against that is
that sometimes he wouldn't bet he didn't
bet every single game so some you could
make the case that the game
he might be like like using his whole
bullpen or like like almost [ __ ] up
the next game after that
like he's just going all out that's
funny one game but
i don't care
who cares
that's pretty it's just funny yeah
they're like it also goes like if i'm a
player on the team i'm like you didn't
bet today yeah you don't really you
don't really have any faith in us yeah
like yeah then there's some games where
he's put in six different pitchers he's
obviously more invested it's like all
right pete i feel like you might have
some money on this yeah that's funny
i didn't even think of that that's great
i like that well i i guess maybe we
should get into some uh comedy content
here talk a little cool yeah sure uh
stand up um
one of the main i mean on the show we we
get to talk to some really funny people
that have have done a lot
in their careers different places and
you've seemed to have been able to carve
out a lot of
notoriety in the podcast game as well as
to your stand up guest appearances your
own show
so how has that been you know because
podcasting is is a new thing relatively
to the world seeing this whole thing
kind of start
how it come up how it's changed how it's
still changing you know now we have
podcast beefs going on like how is it
how has it been to like see this whole
thing kind of start from from scratch
honestly it's like it just seems like
it's i never thought it would be
something like this
where it was podcast i i got into radio
like at a really young age
and i grew up listening to them all so
i'd listen to like stern or opie and
anthony or like don and mike and things
like that
and
i eventually at like 16 started working
on like my local version of those shows
and so
i thought that's how i was gonna do
comedy i wasn't even doing stand-up or
anything else i just thought that was
how i was going to
like have a job in doing things like
making people laugh or like doing
something fun
and then eventually you know as time
went on i realized and i watched and
witnessed you know the downsizing of
radio and like
especially in the corporate radio aspect
where it was like there's less jobs
there's automation they're
not giving as high of contracts because
they're not yielding as much revenue
and eventually stand up once i started
it it eventually started catching up
income wise with radio
and um
you know i always i i remember telling
the people in
my building and in my company that i
work for like we should be putting these
shows on the internet like so other
people can listen maybe people from out
of town like miss
buffalo or whatever and they want
a little slice of home like we could
sell ads on that like they they had no
idea it sounded really ridiculous right
which sounds so common sense now
yeah and so yeah it was common sense
then and it makes me like kind of
angry that they didn't listen to me it
was their own demise at the end of the
day
but
um
you know as time went on
and i eventually like
found my way into
this world
i um
it made complete sense you know what i'm
saying like i was kind of i feel like i
was prepared in a way like
just in terms of like doing them
um what to do because i i watch comics
come in i watch comics come in and do
our radio show or whatever sit in for an
hour and i remember which ones like
resonated and which ones were kind of
like they didn't do you know what i mean
yeah that makes sense
you have so yeah experience that no one
else really had like podcasting to
everyone else is still kind of new but
it kind of is a sim or at least very
similar to radio
yeah it's similar in the fact that you
have to talk into a microphone for
and be entertaining or compelling or uh
interesting enough to keep listeners as
long as you possibly can and have them
come back to you i know what i mean it's
in that it's the same and people have
different styles and stuff like that um
and stand up by uh you know i know ton
of
people who are like amazing stand-ups
like some of the best ever and they
they're podcasting they just
they're terrible do you know what i mean
because they just don't uh they just
turn it on they're like well today i had
uh
spaghetti and uh you know like just they
don't have anything
yeah yeah they don't because they don't
want they're not writing jokes you know
what i mean like it's not
on it's on the fly it's off the cuff
it's
and so um
yeah i know i mean i always wanted to be
on a nationally syndicated radio show
that was like my dream
my whole life or whatever to be like a
arty lang or like a jim norton where i
could like do comedy on the weekends and
be on this radio show
and
you know podcast kind of gave me that
yeah oh sure
it's not exactly the same and i've had
i'm still having
um some like
transitional growing pains from one to
the other because radio it's like it
happens you do four hour show
and you do it every day
five days a week
podcast is once a week and it's one hour
so you would think that would be easier
but when you're doing it so sporadically
it's tough to get in the pocket and like
get it right right right yeah
and then also like people have much more
long-term memories where like if you do
something that blows or they don't like
it or whatever it lives on the internet
forever and they remember it for a whole
week you have to wait a whole week till
you get them back whereas in radio you
could just like you have another
four-hour show the next day you know
what i mean like it took me a whole year
to do as many hours of podcasting as it
would take me to do like three weeks of
radio
that's insane too and yeah
in a form where like practice and
repetition is so helpful yeah yeah
exactly that's and
like sometimes like just an hour a week
like
in comparison to four hours a day like
you can get into your groove in these
longer podcasts that you list that
people listen to like sometimes the
funniest content the real meat of the
show comes like an hour and a half two
sometimes even three hours in because
that's you know they're comfortable
they're in they're in the rhythm of
talking and and they've figured each
other out the pacing and stuff and it's
like
just an hour then it's like all right
that's done it's like that was just the
tip of the iceberg now i have to wait a
whole another week to get another chance
at this with another different person
maybe if it's not by myself and just
completely start over and like you said
if that flops
i have to have that glaring on my page
for a whole week without being able to
like put up another thing to either make
that get lost in the shuffle or redeem
myself um
yeah that's that's got to be a whole
different world but for not only that
it's
the thing about like doing it too and
like executing it creatively and stuff
like that in radio
sure you have people that know who you
are and they tune in and they want to
listen to you and they listen from
beginning to end but some people are
jumping around some people don't even
know who you are and they can just
stumble across it on the dial because
they're just flipping through the dial
and then they go oh what's going on here
like you know what i mean they get
latched in whether they love you or hate
you
and in podcasting it's like
it's deliberate
it has to be like they have to click on
you they start from the beginning maybe
they could scroll or whatever if they
give a [ __ ] but it's like there's no
accidentally listening to a podcast the
way that it was in like a radio thing
and that you see how many of them too
that you're not going to listen to a
random person speak because there's so
many of them that there's going to be
someone that you actually follow and
know and love that you'd rather hear
than trying out it's so hard to try out
a new show
right
like my podcast is very small and it's
very it's still relatively new in the
grand scheme of things but it's it's
very the audience is small but
extraordinarily mighty
and
every time i get like
nervous that it might be too small i
look at like some really
big celebrities you know what i mean and
they have podcasts and then i look at
their numbers and i'm like oh no one
cares they like them in a movie or
something like that but they don't care
to listen to them speak do you know what
it is
it's bananas and and it's almost better
to have like that loyal gang of people
who and that's why i think so many
people love the uh prospect of like
putting all their stuff on just patreon
because it's like only my ride or dies
literally just like people willing to
pay me to speak to them every month are
gonna hear this so like this is just
like a great place to develop my art and
just a place yeah everyone wants to be
here and it's great to siphon people
there and find out who if they really
[ __ ] with you or not but like to grow
it's impossible to do it that way yeah
it just is unless you are unless it's
like a a particular like
um
shooting star of some kind you know what
i mean like if you if say
this person doesn't exist but say
a comic was like just so brilliant
everyone revered them
and they just started yeah and they went
on like rogan and never did a podcast
and everyone's like obsessed chomping at
the bit for more of this person
then they got a patreon you know what i
mean i would that's like the only way
but
comedy is not really set up for like
something like that to really happen i
feel like that's
maybe like exactly a musician could come
on the scene like that but i don't think
i don't think comedy even is built for
for people to pop in that manner
right like not even to
tell like his
deal i mean i just um
i'm like uh hearing it second hand
through him telling it on podcast but
like
tim dillon did his podcast for years on
gas digital
for like no money in a very smaller
audience
and then you know he had a few
appearances on rogan he had some clips
go viral things started
spreading uh
and now he can have a patreon that makes
him a bazillion dollars like that won't
happen
in the world right i'm pretty sure yeah
sure yeah i mean i don't know but
probably i think it is it's like close
to like a quarter of a million dollars a
month because that's crazy he puts it
publicly too which is pretty badass
that's awesome yeah yeah i just meant i
don't know if it was the biggest i i
didn't know if there was anything
i didn't know i mean how many people are
making that much money on it but um
you can't make that number
without starting somewhere and building
a wake of people in terms of an audience
before you create that you know what i
mean exactly yeah that makes complete
sense so um you've mentioned like like
some comedians are brilliant on stage
maybe not transitioning to podcasting or
not
having the the product that you might
expect them to um and then also writing
jokes on on the podcast do you think
that it's more beneficial
not for the um consumer not for the
audience what they think is better but
for the comedian for you to be doing a
podcast by yourself trying to work out
jokes or bringing on other comedians
other friends and doing a
guest conversation
i like a little bit of both but i do
there are certain people i'll say
who
trigger things in my brain that make me
think of things that i wouldn't have
come up with if i was just talking to
myself
and actually you know i do do solo
episodes
and
um
and i just made this revelation we had
some like reason why my producer
couldn't have her microphone on and all
my performer producers by the way had
all their microphones on and the reason
was like noise she was like worried
about
the noise in the room because i kept
wondering i'm like is she just like uh
shy or stage fright or something like
that maybe she doesn't want to be on
microphone so i asked her
and she was like no it's just the noise
in the room and so i'm like well turn it
on because every producer i've had
before has it's been like a conversation
or at least like right when i'm not
making a point or need to like bounce a
thought off somebody
i enjoy doing that because it gives me a
breath to think and then it also like
they could say something that makes my
makes me turn my direction and that was
always the great thing like in radio 2
was like you have a room of guys it'd be
you and like two other dudes or three
other dudes and you're all trying to
make jokes and yeah
it's it's the most fun and i mean those
shows still exist i mean your mom's
house
has that element and uh right that's one
of my favorite things about flagrant too
because uh right there's a bunch of
dudes in a room legend of skank same
thing you know that's why doing a solo
podcast is like tough and i didn't i
didn't set out set out doing podcasts to
do that
but
it was out of contrition do you know
what i'm saying like right
um and also i want i didn't really like
know what i wanted to do at first to be
quite honest like when i was presented
with the opportunity to do it
on your mom's house channel i i just
wanted to do like a radio show and
that's kind of kind of what i feel like
i'm doing like weird stuff but there's
less
other stuff around it so i mean it and
it's only an hour so you don't need all
that other
bells and whistles and things like that
but
essentially that's what i'm doing is
like what you would hear on like a radio
show like instead of doing like local
news and sports or whatever i'm doing
like weird [ __ ] that are about the news
in sports so it's like that's just kind
of what i
started
um it's your lane but i would love to
have
a group of people do you know what i'm
saying like eventually i would grow to
that but it has to happen organically
it's not something
and you can always tell when it's forced
there's a couple podcasts out there i
feel like without naming any names that
are just like
clumped together
uh people because they're like well you
do this much people i do this much
people so let's just get together and do
one yeah there's really no like
chemistry or organic reason for it yeah
then half the audience you're like all
right and here's this new guy and then
the other half right exactly you're like
yeah maybe if you know build it up with
some guest appearances like me if we
were asking for this yeah that totally
makes sense but um you're talking about
your experience in radio and that remind
me of one of the questions like i uh
talked to you before this we put a uh
page in our community section oh yeah
yeah yeah questions to ask josh pyre on
the podcast and someone this is a this
is a pretty interesting question here
from mr sparky 13.
as an ex-radio guy
what would the top three worst giveaway
competitions that ended tragically be
um and if you don't have three
obviously i don't know that many that
ended tragically i only know know of the
famous one that ended all of those
um
i'm trying to think i don't believe
let's take out tragic out of the word
what the top three um
well i mean i have my famous couple that
are just like
uh
brutal like i i um well one was like
we had
and this is so crazy that i did this on
the radio
there was a woman's body that was found
in the river like the torso
okay and there was no head and so divers
were like you know for days looking for
the head of the woman
and um
there was like this little part of the
river where it was like a little
off-shoe people would like i don't even
really know what it was for but it was
like a little bit of a
cut off of the river so like you weren't
in the current of the river but you were
still in the water next to it and it was
like a little bit of a wall there
and uh
i
took that area i put barbie doll parts
inside of the
that and they were all floating and i
put one head in there and i said if you
find the head you win the the prize i
don't even remember what the prize was
but people were all swimming around blah
blah blah
and uh one of the guys was like i don't
know if i can make it back over
and it was just me we don't have like
lifeguards we don't have like it's like
me and like another dude that like drove
the hummer or the van or whatever out
yeah and um
or like the engineer is there who's like
got make sure make sure we're on the air
but none of us are like lifeguards or
anything yeah i was like he's like i
don't know if i can make it i'm like
well you're gonna have to
that's all
i was like i don't know another option
yeah and i mean we made all these people
people sign waivers and [ __ ] like that
but at the end of the day like
i love that
these little pieces of paper don't mean
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying while
there's a real search and rescue going
on and i almost created another river
yeah there's there's another guy
flailing for his life trying to find
this i did say that i said i feel kind
of safe about it though because if he
didn't get swept up in the current they
would have just got him you know a
couple miles down yeah he would have
been fine
he would have been easy to find
that would have been maybe good for
morale for the
did they ever find the head the real
head i don't know i think they did yeah
they found the real head eventually
um
i think so i don't really remember but
uh
yeah i mean that's one and then of
course there's that story we used to do
that too like
it that's just a hacky radio bit the one
that the woman died in she was doing we
for they called it we for we which i
think is a great name and if that woman
didn't die you bet your [ __ ] ass that
would have been done in every station
from seattle to [ __ ]
orlando florida and uh every consultant
would have been pumping that up your ass
but uh we for we is what they called it
we called it don't break the seal and we
did it with coffee and we used the we
used the coffee sponsor tim hortons like
who gave us all the coffee yeah like as
long as we said their name a bunch of
times but but i don't know maybe you
can't
drown what exactly is this
well oh i'm sorry we for so we for we
was water not coffee so it was like they
had to drink water throughout the
morning
and the first person to piss lose like
you're out if you piss basically so the
last person to not piss coffees is way
better for that though because coffee
does the same thing as alcohol where it
like blocks off the thing in your brain
then it just makes you have to have to
pee so bad like i don't i don't mean i
don't know i'm just i all i i didn't
even know this was possible until it
happened but with the water the a woman
drowned herself essentially or whatever
like you can drink too much water and
then just drown and then just like die i
don't i really don't know the science
behind
when you just die
you're like
you can water right it was like when we
all learned every human person learned
you can drink too much water
well that was a good service then i
guess i guess yeah i guess too that's
why i was like i don't know if i was
like maybe we were safer with coffee
like maybe you can't do that with coffee
like coffee is like a diuretic or
something so like
also coffee [ __ ] that's just so much
like more of a punishment to have to
drink that much let alone like
even if you didn't just have to start
[ __ ] yourself or whatever just like
how antsy and by anxious you get by just
being in a coffee drinking competition
like by the end of the day just like
[ __ ] wire dude oh yeah
i feel like yeah you'll even you either
puke or piss like
quicker with coffee than water you know
but so yeah she got like it's like water
poisoning or some [ __ ] i don't even
really know like yeah you
apparently it's something that can
happen
um
and that put a stop to like all of those
[ __ ] contests i mean that was
physical contests well just know just
listeners and i mean and then also the
the decline in radio because i remember
like our show maybe it was the time slot
thing too but like
our show was in the afternoon for a
while and tons of people would show up
and do contests and then when we went to
the morning in the later years
people weren't doing the contest anymore
even if it was like something simple
so
i don't know if that was just like the
listenership declining like in terms of
people weren't consuming radio anymore
as much let alone calling into it and
people
had [ __ ] twitter and instagram and
[ __ ] so they weren't uh
you know using their phone to call up a
radio station for a contest like even
like caller like
13 got to be hard you know what i mean
like
you'd get like four you'd be like the
same guy would be like six numbers keep
doing it over and over i wonder if
there's anything like that because that
seems like so fun for the audience to
like it seem it seems so much yeah
they're gonna be it's it sucks because
like uh i mean there's twitch and
there's live streaming
services and things like that but
nobody's really been able to kind of
make the immediacy that is radio do you
know what i mean i don't know how to
describe it it's like people calling in
with hot takes right away like i'm sure
there are things like it but here's the
thing no one and just like i said before
everyone's actively finding it no one's
passively stumbling upon it and then
calling up and being like what the [ __ ]
are you doing or whatever you know what
i mean so you're missing that element
which when that would happen you'd put
those people on the radio and they would
piss and moan or whatever and
uh call you all kinds of names and stuff
and then the people that like you were
like that was awesome you know what yeah
yeah
there's that kind of like that doesn't
happen there's new versions of that
there's like oh so and so on reddit's
talking [ __ ] or whatever the [ __ ] you
know what i don't know like that's what
the you were talking about the
podcast beefs or whatever i feel like
that's the new like
radio wars you know what i mean like
those things always existed it's always
it's it's just funny that it's happening
now yeah but everything's after the fact
now i feel like because it's like
commenting on a podcast that already
came out like you you stumble across it
and you comment but that's already that
was recorded a week ago or it's like hey
you said this and but like radio gives
you that immediate immediate like
someone's crying and people are
listening live and like podcasting is
all after the fact right and that's the
thing like no how many people and then
once it was done it was done that's the
thing unless you like put it in a promo
or sometimes you know when the host
would go on vacation you'd play best of
mm-hmm and then people would hear it for
they'd be like
oh yeah but you never heard it before
or if they did they just if they did
they remembered it yeah because that's
the thing like people would hear it live
and it's amazing that anything resonated
do you know what i mean while they're
driving a car and yeah yeah listening
for 20 minutes at a time
yeah that's the other thing that you
were saying about like no one just
accidentally finds a podcast but you can
with radio like just flipping through
stations you find you just hear what
topic they're talking about and you have
no idea who the people are but it's like
all right i just want to hear this but
that is so impossible to do now with
podcasting like exactly just like
shuffling through a bunch of random that
used to be half the fun to me and that's
something i'm trying to figure out like
what's the new because i used to love
i mean if you're saying something and it
gets somebody who just the same scenario
you just said where they're stumbling
upon it and then listening to a topic
that they're like huh and they don't
know anything about you and they hear
you say something so wild that they're
like what the [ __ ] is this they don't
know what it is a funny show they don't
know if it's a serious show yeah you
know what i mean they don't know what
they're they're listening to so that was
fun when the
that was like the
it's not like dangerous or anything but
it was like kind of like just like
exciting parts it's like real life like
anything can happen it's yeah it feels
more real
hey guys hopefully you're enjoying this
episode with josh potter so far i just
want to take 30 seconds to talk to you
real quick about atlas vpn and a special
they're running right now a virtual
private network makes all of your
internet traffic travel through one
encrypted tunnel this way protects you
from spying public wi-fi dangers and
hides your ip address as well as all
your online activities besides just
being smart and protecting your data on
the internet you can do a ton of cool
[ __ ] with vpns too like change your
location to different countries your
servers you can watch different shows on
netflix like if you pretend to be in the
uk on your vpn you can watch rick and
morty in the united states
that's pretty cool you're probably like
oh this sounds dope but i want to do
this right now i just want to watch more
josh potter on the joke world podcast
and trust me i do too but this is kind
of urgent because atlas vpn's running
its biggest deal ever right now you can
get three years of atlas vpn for just
139 a month 139 a month is basically
free to protect yourself from the whole
internet
we're back after the zoom pause with
josh potter we've been talking some
sports comedy uh podcasting verse radio
and reading some some questions from you
guys as well
another question
that was sent in was my question to josh
is does the impending full blindness
perpetually take up space in your brain
like do you think about it a lot the
thought of it
and then they said the thought of it
makes their anxiety uh go up
no yeah i do i try not to i mean because
it does make my anxiety go up
and i do like therapy and show like that
so uh
well you're welcome then i guess we're
bringing it up i'm sorry about it oh no
that's all right
that lady she uh
taught me how to like
not think about it i mean here's the
thing i only think about it it's so
weird like i never used to really give a
[ __ ] because it was like my life wasn't
awesome like i was doing all the things
that i wanted to do but i was poor and
like
uh just get just getting by and then
didn't know like where the next step was
or whatever like that so i was like if i
go blind great then i'll get like a
check from the government and i'll go to
a home or something i don't know you
know yeah and then so i'm like whatever
and uh but now that like things are
going good i'm like oh my god i don't
want to go
you know yeah
so that's the only
like that's why i've been thinking about
it more
but um
yeah
yeah i don't know
that's but yeah
but yes i guess
the answer is yes that is yeah
uh so are um are you out in california
right now yeah i live in los angeles all
right then that's been kind of like hit
or miss i feel like since
in the last two three years with their
comedy scene with their open shows with
how's that going like is stage time back
to normal oh everything's back to yeah
everything's back to normal um
everything's open shows are happening
more than ever i mean some places didn't
make it to the other side but
you know new places have sprung up and
yeah
yeah everything's full bore here i mean
did it take maybe longer than other
places probably but uh
you know i don't know it didn't uh
i just did the road you know and i guess
i feel bad for the comics who didn't
have that outlet
but uh
yeah you know i mean i don't it's
to be quite honest like i mean
without covet i've only really lived in
i've i'm coming up in the fall on my
fifth year
so in like six months
but two and a half of them or whatever
were like covered ears so it's like i
was just getting kind of my foothold in
um
the scene if you will but right you know
doing the road constantly it makes it a
little tough to like where were you at
before before that just buffalo okay so
so that was like the first um
was that like this step out of like i'm
becoming like full professional like
going to yeah it was like uh so like in
2017 tom had started doing like a
theater tours and he was
like um
[Music]
you know he goes i'll give you my tour
if you
um
moved to la
and i was like all right so i wanted to
if i say no to that i'm saying no to
doing
comedy essentially and i knew i could
like make enough there was no promises
beyond that year so it was like
whatever i have from
the end of the summer
with full-on gigs all the way through to
like the new year
and
um
then i can you know find a job it's
enough money to like get a place or
whatever so
i took them up on that and you know i
was on the road for that first whatever
however many six months or so yeah and
uh then i had to get a job and so i was
starting you know i'm still doing open
mics here but nobody really knows who i
am and
i didn't expect them to
and uh
you know now it's only like since
right before covid and
since covet has ended that i've been
like just starting to like hang out at
the comedy store more regularly where i
like know the people that work there you
know
i've met other comics that like
we know who each other are or whatever
like we never really hunt you know so
i'm starting to like
just start doing it it's almost like it
would have happened
becoming like a staple three years ago
yeah but it's like not even a statement
not even that but just like being around
like i never was going to the comedy
store when i first moved here like
i uh
i just i was in my place you know what i
mean like i didn't yeah that's right
and now i have like friends who are like
come hang out you know what i mean it's
not like
like now you're a peer at the comedy
store
all right well i'm i'm not past there
and i'm not up here there i don't get to
perform there as often as i would like
or
um but they're giving me i mean and i
don't deserve i mean like we're i just
can't just started coming around so it's
like yeah okay even though you know what
i mean so it's like even though i've
been doing com it doesn't matter like as
far as that place is concerned like
i just started showing up i so it's like
someday but i'm not like in any sweat
but i mean i'm allowed to like hang out
there like people are nice to me
and
uh you know who i am and that kind of
thing like i go there and i'll say hello
to this person or that person they know
my name or whatever right that's not
just like who's this guy but that's back
here
right right right right right right so
was it sad leaving uh buffalo like that
scene that comedy scene there i mean it
sounds like an office yeah i mean
it was sad in that i miss my family and
my friends and like i miss buffalo but
it wasn't sad about leaving the scene i
couldn't care less about the scenes
i never was like
there was always this like
we're a scene or whatever i'm like this
is a [ __ ] solo sport you know what i
mean it's not that i i have my friends
in it and i like
would get hooked people that are my
friends in it that i
thought were like trying at least gigs
and
if that's a scene so be it but i never
had this like camaraderie of like or the
buffalo comics
yeah i don't [ __ ] give a [ __ ] yeah
yeah
so but before the the offer to
uh go on the tour if you moved to la was
that some of your first um
contact or with tom segura or how did
that relationship kind of start i'm sure
no i worked with him for like five years
almost before that like okay here and
there and i mean since he was doing like
it used to be like he would get me the
gigs but i'd have to like
drive myself or fly myself there or like
put myself up or
i don't know if i've ever had to put
myself up usually he'd make sure the
club had a condo at least or something
you know like or the club would put me
up or something you know i don't think
i've ever had to put myself up but i'd
have to get myself there and then i
remember one day he like
went from the also the club started
getting like full
and i'm like this is crazy man you know
i never really listened to your mom's
house i started to like after i'd hang
out with him a little more
and um
[Music]
like
yeah the club started filling up then he
went to theaters and then he went to
like now he's on outer space i mean it's
crazy yeah
yeah he's coming everywhere
yeah dude i mean it's [ __ ]
now his tours are
unreal but i mean like yeah it used to
be like i'd have to
not because he didn't want to or wasn't
generous but it's just the name of the
game like that's the gigs if he were
buying my plane ticket he wouldn't have
made any money on the game you know what
i mean yeah
of course
how is um
traveling the country i feel like in a
comedy setting seems so fun because you
get to you know you have free time maybe
during the day uh in all these different
cities like around the country it just
seems like everyone talks about
traveling the country this and that
whatever it seems like it'd be the most
fun to do it as a touring comedian
because you're also like making
commentary on each city and like
learning about the people
yeah i mean i well i mean i don't go do
like research and make jokes and
sometimes if they strike me but i hate
doing like
i don't try to like go like uh you know
i don't know a local fair but um
i you know i love that that's like one
of my favorite parts and i'm trying to
like get better about like going out and
exploring different things or maybe i
like stay a couple maybe a day or two
extra
because like honestly when there's shows
that night it's like i don't i can't go
do anything if i go do something i'll be
exhausted and i want to like
[ __ ]
i won't i'll be like sleepwalking
through the entire show
and i hate that feeling so it's like
honestly the most some days i'll just
sleep the entire day until the show or
maybe i'll go out and get like lunch or
go for a walk or something like that but
i'm not like
i don't typically i've been to
it takes usually like four times for me
to go to a city to see something that's
like the thing there you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah like now that i'm doing one
nighters and like before when you're
like middling or whatever you're opening
for one of the people they put in the
weekend so it's like thursday through
sunday or sometimes even like longer
than that like wednesday through sunday
but
i mean like when i headline i'd rather
just do like the one-nighter thing if
i'm not gonna sell
a bazillion tickets i'd rather just sell
out like one or two shows on a night and
then i'll stay like like i was supposed
to do
um
philadelphia on june 2nd but they had to
move my date to august 25th
but i'm still gonna go because i set up
like a whole weekend of stuff to do and
i've been to philadelphia like four
times and i i bought tickets to like a
phillies game
yeah there's like a friend i want to see
so it's like i'm just gonna go spend a
weekend in philly regardless but if i
had that one show it would have just
taken up one of the days right right you
know
that makes that makes a lot of sense it
it's almost like when you know that you
have something to do also
like everything you do before that
during the day seems like
that's still in the back your head like
it's not as comfortable exploring a city
when you're like all right now at six
o'clock i gotta be back to entertain and
a few hundred people like yeah i need
like a nap right before
or just to sleep the whole time or like
like i said i'll wake up in the morning
i'll go for a walk
i'll do something but any like sort of
exertion of energy just
even mentally it just drains me so it's
like any like i'll go for like i'll go
get high and like maybe get like a
coffee or something you know what i mean
like all right little knick-knacky
things but i'm not going to like the
statue of liberty yeah you know what i'm
saying
yeah yeah yeah yeah is there any um is
there any club that stands out to you as
like um
a premier club on the road maybe not
somewhere in la or buffalo but like out
there in the country i don't know i
don't i mean like i am
i know more about those ones than i know
about
um here in la i mean in terms of reps
and performing at them
i've been to most of them now and
um various levels of my career so i
could definitely
spout out a couple i mean denver comedy
works is unbelievable
i've never headlined it yet but i and i
was supposed to during covid but i
haven't gotten that uh run back yet
but i'd like to very soon uh omaha funny
bone
is incredible
uh my home club's incredible helium and
buffalo everyone it's one of the better
helium clubs i haven't been to the
philly one yet
i will be but i imagine i mean i still
will think buffalo's is the
the best i've heard of the portland one
as well
the portland helium is electric in terms
of like
like i had such a fun show at that one
that was insane so that one is great too
so all the heliums are are pretty great
um
the
uh
zany's in nashville lucy runs like one
of the best clubs in the country it's
like everyone i mean help people a bunch
of comics instead of going austin moved
there just because of that club so yeah
that's pretty crazy they're developing a
hole
and what's funny is
all the uh i mean it's not funny at all
but it's like people
some people will say
that
you know oh women don't get a fair shake
in in comedy today
and i think that was true in the past
don't get me wrong but i think it's
getting more fair because all those
clubs i named are
booked and run by women you know what i
mean yeah you look at the comedy store
same
uh the improv here in hollywood's book
by a woman all the improvs surrounding
it are booked by a woman
um
[Music]
yeah so i mean a bunch of clubs in
up and down the east coast that are
improvs
that are
uh i mean they're owned by the or
they're booked by that same woman too
it's kind of interesting because i feel
like sometimes most of the literally
most of the clubs that i work i feel
like are booked by women yeah but but
like
i feel like culturally sometimes women
can be the meanest to each other like
everyone's like women oh sure i mean
these women they're not doing it because
they hate women right it's clear they
are one they're doing it based off of
like merit and who's [ __ ] you know
what i mean they're like yeah that's
tickets
who sells tickets really is that i think
it's pretty clear and comedy who
like yeah it's just who you want at your
club there's people are going to sell
out and there's people that you're
taking
chances on and it's like when it's a
real business like that it's it's just
who's funny i don't yeah no i um i've
gotten some some slack on instagram
before because we do this thing where
people can
it can message us a 60-second clip of
them and then we'll post a new comedian
uh try to do it every day uh just for
those people that have like smaller
audiences or they're basically open
micros
it's kind of like kill tony's concept
but it's on instagram so it can happen
right i just post some clips yeah yeah
yeah and
and i've gotten
some people
it was actually just one person that was
reaching out and
sending these long dms about how it's
been like 17 clips since i've featured a
woman this that and
the people who keep the stats are
hilarious yeah and it's like number one
just the way that it's going to see the
math yeah it's just like people sending
me clips way more kids do stand up like
it's just the math yeah that's what i
was it was always like there's no women
on this lineup it's like
in buffalo you'd hear that or something
like and you'd be like there's no women
on the side i called the three and they
weren't available what do you want me to
say yeah
yeah
i tried
yeah
so it's just it's just you know i don't
think anyone
i would hope to think that everyone who
is
participating in like and it's like
that's the thing though they think
because they're like well then i'm a
woman and i should be booked that it's
like or my clip should be promoted it's
like
well yeah but like
or i mean it's like yeah you are a woman
and you are a comic but you're just not
it's it's like you want to know how many
dudes i say no to or whatever yeah
exactly i i it's i like the amount of
clips i get sent to that instagram i'm
filtering out clips based on only one
thing is if i think that it's exactly or
not it's fun and the other thing is i'm
kind of helping the people that i'm not
posting in a way because i'm like i
don't think that's true that's very nice
of you actually
like so i don't know i just to think
that like and also my page of success is
also wrapped up in getting the best
humor out there so it's like if this was
funny why would i just because you're a
woman i'm like that makes no sense at
all to think that but i think that it's
a good
um it can be used as a good excuse
occasionally no sure it's always an
excuse but but sometimes no obviously
there is just like everything else it's
not a black and white sort of
uh a and b situation it's like there's
obviously like
outliers where that makes
it true you know what i'm saying there
are bookers who are [ __ ] and there
are
people who are sexist in this but it's
like
it's not the purveying
yeah
it's not some conspiracy everyone's not
in on it
against you yeah exactly all right well
uh josh potter thank you so much for the
time today before we go just wrap it up
here um just for fun i would like to do
a little bit let's let's do a bill's
prediction for the record this year um
maybe a playoff prediction as well if
you if i assume that you will think that
they make the playoffs and then
i'll do
um a bangles prediction maybe we can
hold hold each other to these
what do you mean a uh playoff prediction
like how far they'll go how far they'll
go maybe a regular season record and
then i mean this is already easy
question i'm going to tell you my answer
right now they're going to go 17-0 and
they're going to go
okay i don't expect anything else i
don't know maybe that was the worst
question but what else
could i even get yeah that's what i mean
i was like what do you think i was gonna
say and they're gonna win the super bowl
i love that dude
a lot of talent in the afc this year
sure no yeah no doubt at quarterback i
okay last last thing it was no yeah was
it just the best thing ever when the
chiefs traded tyreek hill i mean what
well no they traded them to the dolphins
which we played twice a year so
ultimately
it's a weak in the chiefs but it
strengthens someone who is our enemy
that is right next door yeah so it's
like yeah but i feel like they just have
two of us still so two that's why i
think it throws the ball slower than
both those two receivers run
and uh i forget the other guy's name
so fast that they'll just run way past
to a slow left arm throws oh he's
winding all the way back yeah yeah he's
he's never going to get them the ball so
it's almost like north korea where
you're like they got the stuff to make
the nuclear bomb but they're missing
that one
yeah
a similar one but they don't have like
the reactor like that we have we're like
oh you'll never you don't have good
scientists it's just like north korea
the guy in charge is too short
yeah yeah
that's funny that's why i didn't even
feel like it was a threat him going to
miami because i'm like
when i saw that as a person not i mean
i'm i have stake in the chiefs getting
worse for the angle's sake but i was
just kind of like
oh man i like seeing the homes and play
together like i'm just kind of like oh
well you know i wonder how it will
affect them for sure i don't know how to
affect i mean the whole guys are just
gonna do like no look passes to someone
else well now they have juju who i think
is the pussiest player maybe athlete
yeah well jude it's going to be weird
because it's like this could be
patrick mahomes
i feel like he has a terrible
toxic surrounding him yeah even though
he might be a nice guy he's got these
like this brother
he if he wisens up he'll become like
aaron rodgers where he just cuts
everything
yeah people give him [ __ ] for that it's
like
having my own he's a robot patrick
mahomes needs to do that but uh if he
gets juju smith schuster out there juju
smith schuster and his brother are going
to start doing tick tocks together oh my
god it's going to create the most like
epic perfect
it's just going to be the cringiest team
like you don't even and i don't see that
team being the super bowl champion no i
don't i don't see anyone being
intimidated by juju and the the
quarterback's brother like yeah yeah the
tickling around on the sideline yeah
mahomes looks like a tick tock guy yeah
he does that's why i'm so surprised he's
got that fuzzy hair yeah he's got some
his weird his voice is so strange his
kermit the frog just kind of like weird
i just thought of this but what if he's
encouraging his brother like that's good
man
i love her because he's really good
yeah he's just also such a dork or he
wishes that he wants to be a tick tock
star and he just wishes they didn't have
to play quarterback for
half a billion dollars i can't get a
vibe on him at all
i can't either but he it's cool that he
owns a little bit of the royals and yes
that is cool if i if i made that
huge check that generational wealth like
if i'm josh allen i'm buying a baseball
team too you know what i mean like
that's what i've always said if i won
the lottery or something like i want to
own a sports team me too for sure but i
don't think i'd pick baseball
personally
no i get it the other ones are more
expensive though that's true too
all right well anyway
that was a great nfl preview thank you
for being here josh potter um any
socials or upcoming this will come out
wednesday if you have any uh dates
coming up or podcasts or anything that
you want to plug uh tomorrow i'll be in
indianapolis uh
uh
for uh one show and then i'm gonna be oh
that's it for now because i took yeah
because that phillyd that the supposed
to be in philadelphia on june 2nd but
it's now august 25th
and uh i'll be in san diego in july
all of it's up on my
instagram at josh underscore potter and
on twitter
at j underscore potter awesome there you
have it josh potter thank you again no
proud dude
[Music]
you